are you back in love again or are you
still single I'm single you are yeah I
know you broke up with that guy Michael
I love him no I know you always end on
good terms
yeah he seems to end on good terms with
all of his yeah I'm shocked you're such
a good-looking bright ones younger than
me at work
when I'm at work all day long you know
all day long and then I go home and I
have to go to sleep so I don't even I
wouldn't even know where to begin like
someone will just have to find me it's
difficult because you're very busy you
have a very full life yeah but I do love
love my like Saturday that's when things
are quiet and I just have like a quiet
day or you know when I go like oh I'd
love to be spooned well Fred will come
over are you are you on tinder at all no
I didn't know I don't I don't want to
date someone who's on tinder
right cuz you wanna maybe that's rude
but or something but I just I don't she
I don't know I that is the way of the
world and people really meet my sister
met her love on bumble is that right
mm-hmm
I don't know the difference between any
of them yeah I hear some are better than
others I just like there's one Riya
that's for like famous aged people I
mean like I do not want to be with a guy
who's even on Riya but you need to be
with another famous guy you do tend to
date famous people I mean I think it
would be good if it's at least someone
who has a Wikipedia page exactly let's
be honest